for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out Mufi
University com
thank you and enjoy so this video really
the purpose is just to give you a an
idea of what's going on with some of the
basic organic compounds with your
StumbleUpon in general chemistry they're
all gonna be hydrocarbons and
hydrocarbons we should define those
before we go on hydrocarbons are
molecules that contain only carbons and
hydrogen's right hence their name and
they are the simplest type of organic
compounds organic combi compounds are
carbon-based compounds okay now a
specific type of hydrocarbon is alkanes
and alkenes are hydrocarbons with only
single bonds okay these are the only
ones that we're gonna learn about now
just because they're so common now the
formula for a hydrocarbon is cnh2n plus
2 which means that you can plug in any
integer n any positive integer and
that'll basically give you the formula
right so as an example if we have N
equals 6 we would have C 6 H 2 times 6
plus 2 so that would be C 6 H 2 times 6
is 12 plus 2 is 14
so that would be c6h14 and that's
actually shown right here and that's
called hexane we'll get into that in
just a second okay so basically what I
would encourage you to do is just
memorize these basic alkanes and their
names okay the first one ch4 that's
methane and if you could check that's
basically when you plug in N equals 1
right this is ones N equals one this one
here ethane c2h6 N equals two propane
and equals three butane and equals four
so on and so forth all the way up to N
equals 10 for decade ok
now what I want you to know is
definitely the name and the formula now
and when it comes to this though
these first four methane ethane propane
and butane N equals one two three four
respectively
you should just memorize their names and
formulas because they are common names
right common names but for the rest of
them here the rest pentane hexane
heptane octane nonane decane they have
these prefixes right pentane hexane
octane non named any so so they they
tell you how many carbons there are
pentane has five carbons hexane has six
carbons heptane seven octane eight nine
a m-- nine decane ten right and they all
end in aim because their alkanes okay so
that's helpful
basically memorizing the first four
right because they have common names but
the rest you could just think about
using the the prefixes to help you
remember those right the point is though
that I'm really trying to get across is
that you should just know these because
they come up so often just have them
committed to your memory their name and
their formula okay hope that video is
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying